Seattle Washington
known for its great coffee and Superior
produce
just north of the city lies the
up-and-coming neighborhood of Finney
Ridge home to Yanni's Greek restaurant
run by Peter agostillo and his family
my Dad decided that we should open our
own restaurant in 1984 and in 2007 my
dad passed me the torch gave me the kiss
to the restaurant hurry up what do you
need I need another saganaki
when we first opened business
but now it seems like this neighborhood
is changing
[Music]
they open yet and um now people just
don't seem to be coming to Yanni's
anymore I don't know guys I don't know
my husband was stuck in the past
neighborhood's different it's not a
neighborhood that's different it's the
attitudes are different and he doesn't
listen to any of us the melatona dinner
hot potato
written here potato don't [__] tell
me that next time okay you're you're
just spoiled [__] and the only thing he
does is yell where's my plates I need
plates to check it before you serve it
my dad is an absolute control freak yo
yo and sometimes I can't take his
derogatory tone at least let's get going
were you guys in the guidelines my
daughter release is kind of like her dad
that's [__] ridiculous she doesn't
take criticism well I don't think the
man likes garlic no time to get the [__]
out of a Greek restaurant and I think
that that's why her dad have problems
because they have that same personality
back
why are you crying again
she can cry in an instant
stop crying she's known for being very
emotional what now there was too much
cinnamon there's nothing she won't cry
about now what everything was too
garlicky
okay stop it
[Music]
there's so many things wrong with this
restaurant but the main problem Peter
doesn't change you know a lot of our
fixes seem to be really pretty
simplistic excuse me
got the [__] crop I don't have to
change they have to change the attitude
I see things more than you think I just
can't fix everything things have gotten
so bad that we don't have medical
insurance we can't pay our bills on time
the mortgage is always late we've hit
rock bottom
[Music]
of course it's raining
in Seattle before Chef Ramsay heads to
the restaurant owner Peter has requested
some time alone with him hello how are
you sir good to see you at where else in
Seattle but a coffee shop tell me how it
started tell me back to the beginning it
will open 1994 and was this me and my
dad and it was uh very good making money
making good money yes and then uh 2007
my Dad decided that you know it's time
for me to pull back you took over yeah
you know he gave me the thoughts and uh
unfortunately uh our neighborhood have
changed a new Young Generation moved in
yeah and I think they're afraid to give
us a try right you know no good how much
money are you losing between uh eight
and ten thousand
month yeah
how are you surviving I mean do you have
money we've got down staff and
everything else you know so my wife has
to take over the dining room plus my two
daughters work in the restaurants what
do they do the one that works in the
kitchen with me is Elise Elise and then
the other one is uh server tyria how
Hands-On are you uh
Four Hands they gave some
responsibilities to my wife but I still
feel that I have to look over everybody
what's the problem when it comes to
business I don't think they're focused
right you know so the devotion is not
there devotional yeah do they listen to
you
um
what do you like as a boss I'm not uh
strong enough I think you're not strong
enough yeah I give in wow it sounds like
all the pressure are on your shoulders I
mean it is on my shoulders so what's
right with the Russians well I think we
have good product so the food's good how
would you rate that out of 10. if not
ten nine oh wow that's good nine out of
ten is amazing I'm gonna fish on my
coffee thank you for being open and
honest I'll see you back thank you very
much
thank you
hello Hi how are we I'm very well
welcome to Yanni's thank you thank you
oh nice to meet you nice to meet you
he's here yeah no way this is my eldest
daughter nice to meet you and this is
little sis right Elise Elise nice to see
you nice to meet you please take a seat
I'm really excited to see Chef Ramsay
and for him to tell my father you're not
only taking your restaurant down but
you're bringing your family down with
you what I'd like to do is get your
perspective a little insights to Janice
you know there's no no fun anymore you
know there's no frills things are tight
very tight
okay
yeah
I'm sad Terrace is very emotional I'm
sorry
it's tough to see my parents struggle
when they put so much effort
to know that we're struggling just to
barely make ends meet
it's hard
I'm sure it's very hard well how long
has it been that bad you know a couple
years a couple years we're trying to
figure out what what we can do it's
definitely outdated the food is outdated
the decor the decors some of the food is
outdated though too some of the food
could definitely be presented
differently why hasn't it changed I
think
my husband's very stubborn is that
stubborn yeah it's very very why though
he can't just do it have you mentioned
to him have you all the time fights many
faces all the time many fights it's
it's virtually impossible but he told me
he gives in and allows you to do what
you want and he's too easy on you guys
too easy you know two Lacks no no no
never he's not laid back no never but he
raised the food nine out of ten
um he thinks the family are not pulling
their weight he's concerned whether his
daughters are in or out it's hard to be
in when you can't have the full support
that you deserve or when he never
listens to anything you have to say he
says the opposite
he is not that's untrue that's untrue
yes absolutely it doesn't make sense I
don't know who you met this morning yeah
let me go again
Peter my husband is in total denial of
the real issues and why the restaurant
is failing
I need to get to the bottom of this I
mean you know you're telling me one side
the fact that they don't do enough
they're telling me if they're scared to
step up and change because you won't
allow change I'm always the the bad guy
because I want things to get done right
you just said to me an hour ago you're
the relaxed guy you're the one that
gives in but see when I when I raise my
voice I'm a bad guy but it's what comes
out of your mind
how to speak people correctly because
they're not committed they don't focus
on the job the only problem you have
with us no I want you to be a leader
here in this dance
I
don't give a [__] I want things done in
the dining room like they're supposed to
be and I don't think this gets done
they're not servers from the
neighborhood they're your daughters
they're here to do a job
this is a job this is my income do you
want them out no I want them to step up
I can't do everything we're right here
you know I I can't do everything
we've all said we want to be here we're
the ones asking for change what's the
change Decor everything the whole
restaurant move forward throw away the
menu start simplifying
I don't understand why it's such a hard
step you know it's hard for me to just
give up this place it's asking you to
give up change
I couldn't
[Music]
within minutes of his arrival Chef
Ramsay was struck with the negativity
within the family thank you now he's
hoping that he can find something
positive in the food that's not all the
men is surely to help
encyclopedia
five six pages of menu one two three
four five six seven eight nine specials
told my father to change the menu many
many times how'd you remember all these
most of this hasn't changed wow do I do
I do my father is very stubborn and he
needs an Englishman to give him a good
kick in the ass
um am I seeing things pumpkin hummus
pumpkin hummus come on stop yeah I have
been to thousands of restaurants I have
never ever seen a pumpkin hummus it's
not even Halloween
I'm gonna have to try it okay after that
I'm gonna not take masaka if I'm in uh
restaurant okay and the house shower
okay thank you
pumpkin hummus
this is his order pumpkin hummus side
house zero and at the side musaka
wherever the chef wants
The Deco is hideous
it does feel like you're back in the 80s
I've seen it honestly it's like a kid's
bedroom
wow pumpkin hummus
Mama's coming up
make it too oily
wow look at this baby
whose recipe is this this is Peter's
rice
can you join me
[Music]
that does not make sense I don't like
the combination
the garlic in there well garlic that's a
lot oh my God
Garlic's a lot Thomas is really really
garlicky
wow you want me to take that back oh yes
it was a great shame
and one thing for sure
let's get that right there will never be
a problem with vampires here let me tell
you I mean that is hideous
garlic people complain there's not
enough garlic I put blue eggs or garlic
it's too much garlic
like what
there's no wind situation
why are you crying
I don't know keep your head up
pull yourself together
I'm giving him the Musa Club there are
some things on the menu that I beg my
dad to get off because I don't
personally like them
but there's a lot of things on our menu
that I think are the best like the
mustaka I would say that's a 10 out of
10.
wow look at this baby musica lovely look
at that and that's uh freshly baked in
the oven yes nice thank you you're
welcome
it's nice
[Music]
pretty weird the meat is very sweet and
yet the eggplant is very bitter the
eggplant is undercooked
[Music]
picking it apart
the miles off
Osaka
you suck Karen
[Music]
um
it was just so greasy so that is a big
letdown yes I'll let Elise know she'll
be disappointed not disappointed with me
oh wow
any more bad news okay oh my God we used
to cut too oily doesn't like it I can't
make a marinara without oil
this is greasy come on that's ridiculous
[Music]
I think sometimes the sauce though the
red sauce is a little greasy I mean you
can see the oil you want to go sit with
him you want to go sit with him and chit
chat how to [__] criticize my food
get out of my kitchen just please please
I don't need yogurt season out of the
kitchen nice nice nice nice
right now I'm just [__] pissed
what now everything you know it's
outdated it's oily it sucks
stop crying
[Music]
I need a house Sierra a la carte I got
it
oh I want to go out
okay
so the house hero
thank you you're welcome
Tria
yes chef you okay yeah
you sure
come on
oh God she's crying over there
I know it's tough I'm sorry
trust me the only thing so far has got a
9 out of ten is it pita bread it was
food's miles away
as well as it may hurt I am so sorry but
I'm only here for one reason and that's
to get this place fixed I know I
appreciate it okay
[Music]
I hope you enjoy this one
thank you
is in there
come on seriously
it looks like a plate full of puke
look at it
what a mess
Karen two seconds
um oh that's awesome
oh yes yes really yeah when was last
time you tasted this
um I've had it I don't really like it
you walk through the door and you see
the decor dated I didn't think the food
would be Beyond dated all right I'll
take it back
thank you you're welcome
he says our food is dated the decor is
dated our food is dated what the hell
does that mean dated old school cooking
Peter they did [__] amazing It's
[__] amazing you didn't like anything
oh my God I mean [__] this doesn't like
nothing the pita was good how about
mashed potatoes did you like that no
they'd be too salty this is crazy the
longest night of my life
Peter needs to hear these things because
the restaurant needs to change
please maybe Chef can get through to him
because we can
listen you told me when we first met
that your food was nine out of ten I
think so
Peter well there's
authentic food let me tell you that is
not authentic Greek food
pumpkin hummus hideous
there's some things that work with
pumpkin hummus
is not one of them and the gyro whose
idea was it to macerate everything with
the sauce on there is that there's
something we've had for years it's like
a liter of sauce I mean you say it was
bad I don't think it's bad yeah okay
I mean they're so sweet
greasy eggplant undercooked so I had
that bitter aftertasted eggplant at the
bottom
undercooked what is completely white in
the center it's not cooked long enough I
disagree if it's not white and you're
talking you want it black you want it
burnt I'm not asking you to take it
personally take it professionally you
can give me attitude do whatever you
want but if you want me to come in and
blow smoke up your ass and tell you it's
delicious yeah I'm not the one
Peter have you not thought about
changing stuff these are foods I grew up
with what am I supposed to change
you've got to take your head out the
clouds and get into the 21st century I
mean you don't even realize how much
damage you're causing yourself and your
family it's got to stop
I need some fresh air I I'm gonna be
back for service I want to see how this
place functions I don't think
you can be as depressing or what I've
just experienced
[Music]
I still taste that [__] garlic
that was embarrassing I'm not gonna
crumble because one person says that our
food is cracked shut up I'm not even
talking to you
crying
you're just afraid to get rid of the old
menu what do you do with the customers
that drive all the way to come here and
enjoy something that they've had for the
last 30 years old ways are not working
if you're going to survive you have to
change
can't let go of something
I mean we've invested everything into
this place I'm not willing to throw it
away because you can't change a menu
foreign
[Music]
tonight his main focus will be on how
the kitchen operates Elise this is gonna
burn then I'll kick your ass they're not
burning
stick it out I didn't make it you did
don't tell me that next time okay
whatever enough with this I don't need
to babysit anybody here time to grow up
how's that tiro Spano Elise I want you
to read the tickets because these guys
are missing food
learn your job damn it my dad can bark
orders but you're not helping me by just
you know bombarding me with everything
I'm doing wrong
wow how's everything so far
so unhappy with the pork
all right I will be right back
all right dinner coming back
it's full of gristle it bent the fork
and he says at the orzo's overcooked
come on you know it's like the end of
the prisoner what do you expect
come on he said it was I just want lift
my window now okay don't yell at me when
I'm pissed get the lamb out now
[Music]
you want me to take it back yes please
with customers having the same
disappointing experience as he had at
lunch
everything was just bad
Chef Ramsay decides to begin his
inspection of the walk-in
what a mess
no date nothing labeled
key it stinks and it's disgusting
how old is this
stuff disgusting
what is that
raw meat next to cooked meat
seriously
[Music]
what the hell
what is here you're kidding me
chicken oh my God
poor bastard bird
[Music]
at least thank you
Elise why are you guys leaving this I
want you guys right here I am you just
told me to kick food out do you have
something to kick out no because you
think we'll go and the Lamb's not even
ready Ram is ready
just spell that for me just smell it
it's not food there's no food we're not
serving
mold on top
it's moldy what is that it will be
boiled beef yeah but just smell that
pizza just smell it
Elise just two seconds please
yeah just smell that
what does that smell to you oh that's
bad it's bad what about the mold on top
I'm I'm not using that one I'm using
this fresh one if you're not using that
then let's throw away
[Music]
the stickiness of that Elise Elise what
what I I don't know what to say just
touch that
just touch it it's sticky at least yeah
I'm not even using this I don't know
it's old that's the second thing you're
telling me you're not even using it what
about the danger zone of it even just
been in here
[Music]
garbage
Sharon two seconds please this is in the
fridge Peter how long has it been in
here uh probably four or five days that
doesn't go like that after four or five
days come on four or five weeks no way
we don't keep food longer than that so
beef stew with mold on top have you
touched that that was the fat of the
beef don't you dare don't you [__]
dare I've that wasn't fat this chicken
is multi-colored sticky and you're
saying it's four days I don't know how
long it's been in there you don't know
honey do you you and you outside
whatever let me just show you one more
thing
flaming cheese what the [__] is this
it's just little chicken another but
we're not using that are we no but if I
sit here it's 86. do you know what
really [__] me off so no one's caring
there's so many things wrong and yet
everybody's in denial
let me just show you something here
I don't want to do this anymore this is
so embarrassing he's really gonna blast
us like that okay well hello look at the
refrigerator I mean [__] why do we keep
stuff that needs to be thrown away I
don't know it needs to be thrown away
but I'm not the only responsible one
I've never seen this before every
[__] fridge is full of friendship and
old stuff unfortunately the old stuff's
tainted the fresh stuff so what you
think is fresh is no longer fresh and
those poor [__] out there are eating
this
no you can't I'm not gonna let you cook
anymore yeah that's right you want to
continue cooking
you think it's funny do you no Elise if
anyone can walk past rotten food in a
fridge and continue cooking fresh you
shouldn't be [__] anywhere near foods
and then when I hear Paul I've never
seen that before then open your [__]
eyes
just don't believe this you know what
happened to Czech things
I don't know what happened
what the [__] is this do you guys like
this [__] to drink it don't leave that
it's in there for so long
look look in there
that's embarrassing that we don't use it
I can't keep up with everything I
[__] babysit you like kids and you
still [__] me I don't need to babysit if
I want to babysit I don't babysit my
granddaughter she's more fun than you
guys
what is this Chef Ramsay's inspection
led to some shocking disgusting
discoveries every fridge is full a
friendship an old stuff and Peter is
pointing the finger at everyone else
I've maybe said you like kids and you
still [__] me if I wouldn't babysit I
don't babysit my granddaughter she's
more fun than you guys
that's just like my father you know
pushing the blame onto everybody else
and not taking responsibility
frustrating I'm sorry I I just want to
know our table's getting our food
there's no food to real tell people I'm
real sorry whatever they have is free
I'm really sorry
just close the line down man I don't
give a [__] what you guys do
[Music]
foreign
no one's getting food comp them for
whatever else they've had okay just tell
where to tell them that we're done
[Music]
we're having some problems in the
kitchen and you know we hope that you'll
come back again drinks around the house
thank you for trying us
and have a good night
this is not fair
I've never seen food like that
oh my God
[Music]
foreign
things should be labeled things should
be dated things should I mean we
it's basic
basic
[Music]
last night Chef Ramsay was disgusted and
disappointed in the mess he uncovered in
the kitchen today he is hoping that
Peter and Elise are no longer in denial
good morning come through please come
over let's sit down over here
right how are we feeling a little shaky
a little shaky yes sir you know with the
events that happened last night uh I
think we're all embarrassed uh we're
here to
listen to you to show us a new way to do
things
but at the same time
I cannot let go some of the things that
happened last night
like what give me an example the
refrigerator
back there it wasn't as bad as I made
out yes
what I saw last night
was disgusting
your refrigeration unit was one of the
most disgusting fridges I've ever seen
you are the owner and it's about time
that you sir start taking responsibility
for what you're running we are about
first food and I'm not gonna serve my
customers any spoiled food if I know
it's spoil never the food that we served
last night it was fresh yesterday
morning I made this food so you cannot
tell me that we're sitting in the
goddamn refrigerator and collecting mold
and all that [__] we don't leave things
like that that long so you clearly don't
know about the spoiled food in the
fridge then do you think I'm going to
serve that
why is it there my employees are not as
stupid to do that oh really and we get
it and I just sat there like nothing's
wrong I never said nothing is wrong I
said I would never serve that I know but
it's our fault and we make up all these
excuses stop the excuses let's just go
forward yesterday was a disaster
disaster so can we put that in the past
and just walk forward to these people
yesterday last night it was fresh do it
today
so you can tell me that
let's get real shall we
because you're not gonna listen and
you're not gonna take responsibility I'm
done
oh God I'm out of here
with Peter refusing to really comprehend
the problems of the restaurant
to these people yesterday last night it
was fresh during the day Chef Ramsay is
wondering why he should continue to stay
I'm done oh God
last night I
bet it was reality in our face we have
dropped the ball this is not what we are
not what we are but it's our fault we we
can't blame anyone it's our fault we let
it happen
we need to step up and take back the
restaurant
are you willing to work with us Chef
Ramsay I mean do you think that we're
savable I'm trying to but when you can't
accept the real problems there's no
chance
[Music]
I need
help for improvement
help us
show us the way
please
we love this place we live for this
place
my life is this place
I haven't given up but my focus has been
gone I need your help to pull me back to
where I was before
I think we need to not go back to how we
were when we were successful we need to
move forward and reinvent it yeah you're
right
Peter we've got to let go of the past
I've got to change
even though change is scary
you need to you need to change
we have to change our ways
Giannis cannot succeed like that anymore
I cannot stay open like that
and this is my reality check
and Peter
here's another thing what I saw last
night wasn't pretty
Peter mu was so negative and if Elise is
determined to be in the kitchen
[Music]
you have to nurture her and support her
do you ever tell her she does a good job
never no it shows
I mean I'm sorry if I yell out to you
guys before you know maybe with no
reason and stuff but the pressure was on
and
well I guess I didn't know how to
relieve the pressure or how to fix the
pressure at the end of the night when
it's all said and done well instead of
calling the chef frames in here to make
you say it you could say it once in a
while well like I said things are going
to change
good
it will change
do you mean that
I do
100 I'm not a man that backs down
I'm not in egomaniac no I have a bride
we're moving forward moving forward
I really hope that he's willing to
change not only our relationship but
everything
long overdue
now that Peter appears to be open-minded
Chef Ramsay has an assignment for the
family modifying the major thing that
Peter has been most stubborn about book
for you a novel for you and let's talk
about you and you're not going to share
the menu
look at each and every page together and
throw out what's not selling get ready
to cut out a lot I'll be back in five
minutes okay
set an olives no that's must souvlakis
no
chickens
out no that's not out seriously come on
chicken dishes people come in here
they're used to this manual and
people are gonna come I don't want to
lose this man new people are gonna come
no we're changing
I mean this is your time to change it's
like walk away from the menu take it out
how many items is to begin with
too many
oh my God
I didn't realize so many I've had this
menu for 28 years but I think it's time
for me to listen to others leave my ego
out the door 55 Iron Man I never I just
that's the only way for this restaurant
to succeed okay we have to
it's out
okay chicken status off off
I can't believe
the Sharpie and cross off all these menu
items we don't need those Saucy beef
dishes out this is the first time I've
seen my dad actually listen to my mom
and my sister and I and not have to take
control of the situation wow okay good
that's our menu wow just just that on
one page
64-21
and wait a second are you smiling yes
this is weird
there's no tears and three or even
though
this is the new Direction and I and
we're all committed now as a family to
make this happen yes that's given me a
lot to work with I'll see you later
thank you
yesterday I wanted to kill him
[Laughter]
with the family recommendations in mind
Chef Ramsay heads to the kitchen to work
and perfect the new Yanni's menu while
his renovation team overhauls the dining
room
[Music]
good morning hi good morning first of
all how is everybody feeling do you have
a vomit bucket oh Jesus
wow oh boy I want all of you to take
your blindfolds off
oh wow oh my God oh my God welcome to
New Yanni's it is stunning whoa that's
it oh man how beautiful is this
restaurant oh my God it's gorgeous when
I walked in here it looked like you
hadn't updated since 1984. welcome to
2013. that is so nice oh my God
Pizzeria it's nice to see tears of joy
let me tell you gone is that depressing
wall oh yes we've replaced it with an
amazing gradient paint job oh you know I
love the blue I love how it just Fades
out the wine barrels have gone too and
look we got rid of that hideous dated
stained glass and owned up with
wonderful wooden trim and the restaurant
looks twice as big now oh gosh also I've
arranged for a complete delivery of
brand new China courtesy of Niagara
China oh my god oh wow
oh you okay bud
come here bud
come on up oh man how how are you doing
my country
you're the best to see my father so
happy it's such a great feeling his true
emotion showed today marks the greatest
day ever
at Yanni's Greek restaurant
there's one more thing I need to show
you I think it's going to really help
organize you in a way that you've never
been organized this is your new
POS system oh my God oh my God
[Music]
this is the POS lava system from Zephyr
Hardware this is unique service take
orders on touch screens orders go
directly into the kitchen wow no more
trying to figure out what does this say
and this comes with an amazing new app
that can be controlled from anywhere
even from home it will tell you what's
going what's not working it will tell
you what your top selling dishes it will
give you a detailed report instantly oh
my God this is going to make this
restaurant run seamlessly wow
this is a new day at Giannis wow thank
Chef Ramsey
now the Johnny's Decor has been revamped
Chef Ramsay has taken the family's pair
down menu and created fresh Innovative
modern Greek dishes we've kept your
classics
and we've modernized your approach to
the Mediterranean Cuisine dig in all
right enjoy where should I start I think
I have blinders before thinking my food
was great but now that Seth Ramsey it's
always new dishes I'm ready with Peter
fully embracing the new direction of the
restaurant are you ready pumped up baby
Chef Ramsay spends time teaching Elise
and Peter different techniques in the
kitchen just touch them by doing that it
flattens the skin okay which then gives
you a nice solid base Chef Ramsay is
boosting my confidence so much by
teaching me the science behind the dish
and it's amazing kids your plate is
exactly the same as my plate this is the
way you too should be working together
in harmony
at the start of the relaunch service
Peter and Elise began to battle I call
I'll call him back you call me then call
me yeah I'm you just told me wait a
minute calm down at least he's
Expediting listen to her but Chef
Ramsay's enforcement of a new system got
them back in sync at least that's just
gonna be up to you then to stay strong
making sure that we are staying United
as a team new ticket
three chicken with potato
es together guys
yes I got it in there good Chef Ramsay
is right instead of focusing on the
negative and fighting constantly pick
each other up
as for the dining room this may be one
of the most successful relaunches ever
how's everything tasting so far
customers raving about the food for the
entire evening
they're very happy they're all coming
back
[Music]
Peter and Elise working in the kitchen
and actually him being happy and proud
of my daughter I mean it's Priceless
watching all of you work together
it's beautiful thank you for helping our
entire family come together I am
energized for the new Giannis there is
no words to thank you enough the future
for yani's restaurant it looks great
right now we won't let you dance I want
to make him proud I will serving the
best pumpkin hummus I've ever made I was
just a joke
look after each other
now I'm gonna miss this guy come back
this went from one of the most
depressing kitten nightmares ever to one
of the most uplifting and in a matter of
days this restaurant leaped 30 years and
it's now an excellent Greek restaurant
and I can't ever remember rooting for a
family more than this one
wow
pumpkin hummus
what next
in the weeks that followed Peter adapted
to all the changes made by Chef Ramsay
father and daughter continue to work
well together in the kitchen all right
our half chicken the family is also
happy to report that for the first time
in a long time Taria is doing a lot more
smiling than crying it's a new bright
day
I'm not crying